somebody says to you you know what is a
woman and you don't know you don't think
Hano itself it's like a bit anti-women
because panel uh like mine like the the
show panels we don't really have like
you know you don't have a there's only
panels of gas yeah yeah but I think
she's I think she's just saying the
podcast is anti-women you know it's like
why would she come on then if it's
anti-women oh she did I didn't know it
was only women until I got there when
you say something she she brings all
these stats yeah to basically hahaha
you confused her with the stats why
don't you go with your feelings why
didn't you go with yourself it's gonna
be something she's lacking in her
argument yeah she has zero facts to
support and the thing is is that when I
go to church and every if the if the
pastor says something I will write it
down and I will go but I won't say yeah
yeah I believe him I will write it down
in a book and I can I've got years of
them every time I go to a church I write
down what they say and I want to go and
look for it for myself and I mean
everybody keeps announce good where'd
you get these stats from why don't you
say the stats I know I always say Google
it Google it you want to find out Google
they're never happy even if I give it to
them like I was on this podcast and
they're if you're talking about body
count I was talking about the data on
body count they said where I said the
CDC the Center for Disease Control and
and they're still not happy they're
never happy now you make up statistics
how many times have you given a fact and
a guest changed their opinion because of
the fact they're like you know what I
was wrong the point I just made actually
the shows we've been doing are more like
they just haven't been geared this way
but like I didn't show and there's a
couple people that said they were going
to be pro-life after the show and the
thing is that not the majority I would
seem to be like 10 20 but even thousand
of us to you know be an influence and
changing them on if she's wrong you've
done that with zooby you know I remember
you had a percentage and when he
explained himself you were like you know
what I'll give you an extra 10 I think
you said or something like that so even
pearls I mean my view is like if you if
you think I'm saying something wrong
prove me wrong change my mind and prove
me wrong but don't say that I'm wrong
but you can't tell me where I'm going
wrong you know it's it's stupid and then
stats you prove like my conversation she
was saying that women are bad with money
yeah
black the guy just said which they are
she's still cutting across still cutting
across him and he said women are bad
with money background like African women
are the best with money is that how you
feel yes no no but listen to my words
I'm saying do you do your steps
according to African women Caribbean
women white women American women aren't
the statues women in general it's the
women owned two-thirds thirds of
Consumer Debt worldwide I actually was
looking into Nigerian women um their
credit card debt
um if it's a sacredit fraud no no no no
no no no no no no no I couldn't find
much data on like specifically Nigerian
women because it was that was you know
um I think that was one of the ones she
said
um what I found was like I think women
are locked out of credit card markets
there and I'm like maybe there's a
reason
there's a lot of fraud going on that's
why so that's why they have to be good
with cash okay is how you feel though no
it's not about how I feel my reality
women are very good what do the stats
say I don't feel but my reality your
reality is still your feelings because
not stats what are you gonna back it up
with my reality she doesn't live in the
reality because she doesn't know what a
woman is talking about a discussion
now there's shouting all over the host
it's his show shut up yeah that's the
how many y'all you know what I know
they're gonna watch this and I just want
you both to know how many times have we
counted I can't even count how many
times you've interrupted hosts that's
right and then when I'm talking about my
point of view and then what I was
getting was in so in comments so
um it's Auntie Jenny that's me
I can be rude
[Laughter]
I love you Eddie
people you can disagree with someone's
opinion without like saying oh you're
just confused now if I'm asking you as a
woman what a woman is
and you're telling me that you bleed
three times a month
and then you corrected yourself and said
oh no I only bleed once come on you
don't know how many how much you believe
and then we'll explain to you about
biology and you are saying that being a
woman surely can't be about biology
being a woman is about feeling like a
woman so anyone that feels like a woman
can be a woman of course I'm gonna say
you're confused I still stick with that
you are confused you're upset with me
that you're confused because you are a
woman and you don't know what a woman is
now you're upset because I called you
confused look at the podcast you are
confused so this is this is social media
but even coming but no I feel like you
can just be like oh I hear what you're
saying I just don't agree because my
reactions
[ __ ] we don't want that's what people
want to see but even coming he's right
she did chat [ __ ]
they want to see the questions to your
podcast did you bring her Eddie's the
one that said that you recruited him and
they said that they yeah
right because I didn't even know she was
going to be there Attica to make sure
that people are not being insulted it's
etiquette not to interrupt people when
you're on a podcast
nothing to do with pearl you are warned
about the super chess before you start
the show and if you make you and Paul
always warns you if you make yourself
look like an idiot they will come for
you yeah I tell them before I always say
that super chats are mean if you don't
want somebody to know something pulses
don't say it don't say it so because if
they come at you purses it's not my
fault so she can't accuse Pearl because
you know that Pearl's gonna read out the
super chats everybody knows that Pearl's
going to read out the super chats so how
can you blame Pearl for the super chats
you were acting stupid you acting
confused so of course she's gonna have
to say something I gotta say that
because she didn't know what a woman was
she did not know what a woman was so of
course I'm gonna say that she's
racist they were racist they are they
said things like white where did you
bring this to generate Nigerian women
okay hang on wait till after that he
says something I remember he says
they've called other people
they said you are degenerate a Nigerian
which is what the person said but now
because she's realized that she's up
there saying oh I'm Nigerian now they
realize she's a degenerate Nigerian
she's trying to make it sound as if all
we're saying all Nigerian women no love
I know some really good Clipper Nigerian
women you're the one you're the one as
the man said they are talking about you
and you know what I feel like I feel
like they they clarified this because
okay I feel like it's because normally
Nigerian women are not degenerates like
I think that's why they said it was
because like it's abnormal they couldn't
say like I like I've had so many
Nigerian women on their show on the show
and they're usually like more submissive
they're usually very much believe in
like respect to their husbands and that
sort of thing but the thing is they
couldn't say degenerate woman otherwise
that would be bad for all women they
couldn't say degenerate black woman
because otherwise that would be for all
women so they had to say you are where
did you get this degenerate Nigerian
from this degenerate Nigerian not all of
them she must be the only Nigerian woman
in the whole world that doesn't know
what a woman is of course they're gonna
say that she does not know what a woman
is
he's generating Nigerian women that's
suggesting that Nigerian women are they
said woman they didn't say women
generally no it's not but it's also
she's not representing just Nigeria
though you're just talking about it she
come up there and all Nigerians are
proud to represent Nigeria everybody
comes on this oh I'm Nigerian I'm from
this this is my tribe they all do it
they all do it no I don't know it's like
the Obi tribe and then there's like two
words so I mean you know about them
or something yoga or Yoruba or something
and I I mean I Loosely know about it
because like literally there's so many
Nigerian people that have come on the
show and they're all so proud yes
if you just said oh I don't agree with
what this woman is saying fair enough
that's not reality bringing my Nigerian
into it that's basically custom Nigerian
and she's born and bred here by the way
right are you starting a podcast she's
born and bred here so what they're
trying to say that they should call it
English now if they call if somebody
says to me oh English woman I always say
oh somebody says where do you come from
as a a black woman you don't even know
born here you don't say oh I come from
England you always say oh I'm from
Barbados or I'm from Nigeria Mo I say
like 90 of your black guests that come
here are actually born in the UK but
they don't say that well and I think
it's not normal to say that you're
you're black British unless it's in the
form and I think it's a common like
second maybe third generation thing
because like I'm so far removed like I'm
mostly German Irish like Lithuanian well
yeah like those but further up but
further back they would have said oh I'm
from Germany just say American yeah but
I put myself in her shoes I'm like okay
if I was if I was from like so I would
say I don't know I don't even like this
word identify the most with I grew up
with German nannies yeah so I kind of
know about them yeah true the mouse and
if they said like this degenerate German
woman I wouldn't say that's racist yeah
you just say that's what you want
if he was
and she understood podcast etiquette she
shut her mouth and tried listening and
let other people speak she obviously
don't understand it how would I bring my
guest on and I see didn't bring her on
she came on like derogatory comments and
actually read it out to my guests but
you know she's gonna read it out it's
printed
a super chats are going to be read out
before the show starts it's all there
don't chew gum go to the toilet now
switch off your phones don't move down
the mic and then Pearl stands up and she
always tells you about the super chats
you know they're going to be read out
but because she wasn't shown in a good
light that's why she's upset and she was
shown in a good light she wouldn't be
upset and some of them are really nice
yeah and the thing is like oh that's
some nasty ones have you yeah when I
when I would go off on one on the rare
vacations and you know I stood by it I
think I apologize once because I
realized like I did go over the top but
yeah but um overall like they can be
really nice too and sometimes they're
informative and the thing is like
there's just so many super chats that a
lot of times I don't even that's why I'm
so bad at reading them there's so many
and I don't even know what I'm reading
half the time exactly
until after I read it and occasionally
if they're really bad I might I might
skip one if they're really really bad
but that's like oh you were born them
I've had to warn people like you know
I'm sorry like I've seen the super chats
I'm gonna read them but you know
especially the young ones you normally
like say like don't it affect you and
I'm really sorry but you know this is
what you say but it's not me you always
say it's not me and and the other thing
is like to me I just feel like if people
will be like oh it's about them like
because I think they're gonna say so you
know it's about the money but it's not
about the money it's about that like I
know that the people watching like a lot
of times this is the highlight of their
day they've been working a 40 50 60 hour
a week job and they're still choosing to
give me a Super Chat because they think
that I'm going to read it and I feel
like like am I gonna take away money
from the average person like okay if
they go crazy far and I and I actually
clock it before I read it sure but like
it's more about like that these people
are supporting me and sending their
money and I just think if someone is
doing that like especially like they're
average people and some of them just do
it for fun to hear you pronounce their
surnames Mr rojovski or whatever his
name is you know yeah the way you get to
I'm putting it up I watched that one
he's I'm gonna say it to see if she can
say my surname again was it a Russian or
German surname yeah and he kept on
saying it but she knows what it's all
about guys you know you know them guys
that you're saying that's reading them
comments they're your biggest followers
do you need them what are you gonna do
in comments and say yo don't come out
you've just hit the point no but you've
just hit the point yeah I will start a
podcast because I want to change mindset
not for money I don't do it for money
Paul is doing it for money two different
things and she's pushing a narrative
which is toxic for society I want to
benefit men and women so we get along
and we have a better life she wants to
push this narrative and make this hate
wider can you tell me okay now this is
the funny thing now technically it's the
girl next to it's not her but okay I
want to tell you something that happened
Auntie Jenny so oh you kind of you kind
of know this but I'm gonna tell I'm
gonna tell everyone blessing buckle up
Kobe buckle up so girl on the left
apparently doesn't have a podcast girl
on the right has a podcast now she
invited me and Auntie Jenny on now let's
let's be wrong me and Auntie Jenny get
more views than these girls will ever
get in their lives I'm not gonna lie
about to use my followers for rubbish
because they were they're gonna they're
gonna follow or they're gonna watch that
podcast if I appeared with her just say
what I've got to say and not only that
she knows about podcast
etiquette right but yeah when we watch
this listen to how listen and listen to
how they're going to treat us and how
why they want us to come onto their show
you'd hear it I'm females
but okay so she says it's not about
money right so why do you want us on
your podcast she said I thought it was
about conversation well if it's about
conversation we can have one not in
front of the camera if it's about
conversation she'd learn to shut her
mouth and have one when she's on the
podcast and two and two so what I said
what I said because why would I reward
you for bad behavior I again I'm very
thankful to the people that helped me
early on there are people especially
early on like daily on that podcast like
he helped us move when we moved into
this new apartment he helped us do it
and there's a lot of people that like
did stuff like that that I'm more than
willing to help um I went on I can't
remember the name but there's another
like smaller podcast in London I went on
and
I'm more than willing to do that but
like you're gonna trash me and then
expect me to go on a podcast for free
when typically I have a large fee that I
charge people and I only don't like if
you're one of those people that I feel
very grateful to so I said okay let's
let let's let domino effect make the
money we won't do it on my podcast I'll
offer you my studio let's let's let that
podcast make the money off of it because
it's not about it's right it's not about
money for them and they they call they
call Eddie and they're just like oh
convinced her to come on convince her to
come on like no we want it on our
podcast well if it's not about money you
should you should do it on Eddie's
remember that didn't I when I when I
agreed I said that when she said oh can
you come on my podcast I said I will go
I will meet her at least Miss I don't
know I'm a woman I miss I will go onto
the Domino effects podcast with them but
I'm not willing to go onto her podcast
so I'm not avoiding you she's like talks
about it about what she said no like
you're saying she